yeah welcome to the video this will be a
kind of wrap up video for the Talmud
Morgan memorial in Moscow we did some
dual commentary's for the first three
rounds like a game of the day stuff but
last week on yeah kingscrusher and I we
didn't really managed to to make further
game of the day with these videos we
were just too busy um so I'll do some
sort of wrap up video here to to get a
proper end of the video coverage for
this tournament so um today was on the
last round and quite surprisingly at the
end there's a soul winner it pretty much
looked like there would be some yeah
more than one player finishing on shared
first but at the end and the winner is
some yeah Magnus cards are from Norway
or what number 1 i'm quite surprising at
the end because he was never in the lead
in this tournament except for the final
standing after round nine and this is
yeah what matters in the end um at the
end he scored five and a half points out
of nine which is a plus to score winning
two games sorry and playing seven
drawers on which may be sounds kind of
peaceful to to some people but if you
look at the games it didn't play a
really short draw without any content
there was a quite short draw for
instance against Kramnik in the first
round but it was some kind of Perpetual
where I couldn't do anything to avoid it
otherwise he was very often the last
player on playing and yeah I think I
don't have a statistic on that when I
pretty sure he's gotten the most moves
on average maybe Nakamura is close but
he's literally fought hard and try to to
win more games but it didn't materialize
so at the end I'm plus 24 Carlton and
I'll show a shout second and third place
there so
kara wanna and raja baath maybe i can
actually try to to get this on video
this possible I can try yeah okay as you
should hopefully you see that the final
standing now this wasn't really a plan
beforehand but it's also been built in
Germany but I think the main point is to
show that the table here so plus two for
Magnus and plus one for a job of
ankarana Kara wanna actually was looking
like the tournament winner before last
round he was leading a loan before the
last round plus two but then lost to
alone Young in the final round and this
actually allowed Magnus to to win the
tournament with a victory against Luke
McShane so our job of shared a second he
won against McShane thomashefsky de for
the both tell ender son of the
tournament and lost two cars in very
front end game on Carla's part and yeah
then the tragedy tragedy of the
tournament and the story of the
tournament is more Savage who started
with four of five plus three which was
enormous I think close to three thousand
seven ELO performance and then he
actually lost three games in a row as it
turned out if you look at it now he lost
were the three last places in the
tournament on I mean okay last place it
is still a very strong play and those
kind of events so you cannot really say
okay he lost you to the pats s or
anything else this wrong way to see it
of course but when he came from + free
and then lost three in a row to finish
at fifty percent at the end so he
basically had the tournament in the back
and then sort of broke down yeah aronian
really never get into get got something
going in this tournament at the end
managed to to get fifty percent with a
win over Caruana but somehow yeah he won
the first game and he won the
game first John in last round and in
between it was quite bleak for standards
yeah Kramnik also cannot be satisfied as
he had plus two at one point and was
looking like he could could fight for
the tournament win here and then he lost
two in a row which is also very unusual
against kawana way some very young
somewhat miss played a young a half
middle game event came and he lost to
McShane also and we try to win some
position I'm not sure maybe this was a
bit too risky he was really trying hard
to win this game and somehow it turned
out that McShane chances were better and
he made everything out of it yeah grigio
gone fifty percent um I think he won 22
nice games against Hikaru and and Luke
McShane he was pretty clearly to kramnik
and also to more savage when he was
still on his run so um yeah I'm not sure
he won't be satisfied maybe but it's not
too bad on paper like a [ __ ] minus one
he certainly won't be satisfied with his
ambitions but he lost pretty pretty
clearly I think to Greece yaku in a
dragon way never really had anything it
looked like at least and young I think
he would have certainly wanted more yeah
McShane played a very fun tournament
winning three games losing four I have
not sure how to how if he likes this
result or anything he had three wins
against Aronian Kramnik and and more
savage so especially the blacks against
Aronian black wind was very remarkable
and beating Kramnik also doesn't have
himself yeah Tomashevsky on last place
who really had this kind of debut in
such a such strong field and he played a
little bit too cautiously maybe know how
to tell um but well- to it's not it's
not super terrible i think in
like three or four inner points or
something in this kind of field minus
two is not terrible he won against
Morrow but lost also three games so he
certainly hoped for more but it wasn't
wasn't terrible alright so this is about
the final standing and a quick overview
how the players DTM I think it was a
very exciting tournament with lots of
decisive and interesting games yeah for
the sake of the the tournament standing
on for importance at the end I I picked
at the wrap-up game here on the ricotta
the McShane against cards and from last
round where Magnus needed to win to to
catch at first to catcher at least
Caruana and maybe overtake him if he
loses which actually happened in the end
so yeah countless black against McShane
and he certainly wanted to try to keep
winning chance so let's see what
happened on McShane open deform would
she I think constantly did in this
tournament usually you play t4i it's
it's it's normal move and Magnus goes 45
which she plays the most of the time
here the first time I'm very interesting
point arrives early here a Magnus also
plays 96 the the Berlin Wall and often
you get this kind of endgame but their
white has at least one cup outline where
you can yeah pretty much player play for
a draw let's say here and this kind of
position is very hard for black to
trying to win I mean the normal Berlin
Wall is hard to win anyway with black
but this kind of position is pretty much
yeah debt in terms in terms of winning
chances which was also which was played
by McShane also with white against
crumbed again he actually got a little
bit self something in this game okay so
I'm not a good idea if you want to play
for window to go for the bull in defense
someone has played on a six-year the
most popular move now Bishop a 49 f6
castles it should be seven so the
absolute main line of the the ruler pass
and white ear usually plays rookie one
and you get all those kind of main lines
like here cards usually place the brier
variation here this night be 897
maneuver and this usually needs to a
quite complicated maneuvering game where
white normally enjoys slightly better
chance because of this space a space
advantage in the center but it's the
kind of position where black and Scott I
mean there are all pieces on the board
usually it it's like this here just just
to put up the general configuration or
black even sometimes place just c6 here
get a kind of position where all pieces
are on the board there's nothing
exchanged so you can hope for a long
complicated game when maybe
complications will turn up later and
which even allow black to to try to play
for win just because the position is not
simplified you might get fighting
chances later so this was maybe what
Magnus was up to but McShane played
entirely different line he captured on
c6 here the on yeah did the deferred
exchange rule Lopez and the idea of this
is following black take the d porn here
to get his bishop out immediately so you
will have some some development going
for him and the the difference between
this kind of setup and the norm of
roller passes that black already has
those two pieces played 90 f 6 in Bishop
187 and in this kind of position it's
actually questionable if this is such a
great setup if black would have had the
choice he
have played those moves most likely very
often in the exchange rule Lopez black
for instance place the move f 72 e 6 i'm
there for protecting me five this this
point with a pawn and now in this
position oops in this position makes a
plane plenty three and now the
difference is this e5 pawn doesn't have
a convenient yeah that's a convenient
way to cover this pawn immediately with
a move like f6 so black basically needs
to move a piece again to to protect the
porn which Carlton did with 97 and this
is yeah the point of whites player that
black needs to lose time here to protect
the pawn um in in this this structure
white um has two main main ideas and
they're connected to with porn pushes
one possible porn pushes d3 2d four at
the latest stage to get the typical
situation where black captures here we
can we can see this later and the other
idea is to play for 4f form so it's the
spawn de-spawn levels that you can go
for which are the main ideas it's very
often the case that the main form breaks
are other themes and the positions i
mean white cannot reach any specific
goal here with peace play alone so let's
see what happens you played b 3 which we
pass the fianchetto of course and sort
of stabilize the Queen side in a way
black castles we should be too and now
f6 um yeah f6 is some a move urges has
its pros and cons the positive side of
courses that the pawn on e5 is now very
yeah very reliably covered with another
porn the downside is that like somehow
weekend this white squares a bit
this is a thing you need to take care of
um now white went 93 which is a bit a
bit of an uncommon set up here and I
looked it up I mean it looked strange to
me but it was really a it's rarely
played on what white usually a place in
this kind of position is actually at the
most popular move at least is a d4 here
actually um that black gun takes Knight
takes and then we got this pretty
typical on pawn configuration for from
the Reno past exchange line where black
or white has these four points against
three and blanket as a compensation has
got the two bishops so from structure
point of view white it's nice here but
black ass also has chances because of
the two bishops play might continue
along these lines in 95 to a techie form
white covers and then the roof like rook
e8 followed by possibly night Bishop
back here or Bishop to d6 and this is
well maybe about equal may be very
slightly better for white it's an entire
entirely different position compared to
what we got in the game so make shrimp
let this Knight c3 move and as I
mentioned the other possible break in
this position is the f4 move to the
check that you five poly and this is
what why does it seems it's playing for
now black went rook e8 and this is a
very good move because it prepares the
the very much key the key maneuver that
black needs to know in this this kind of
position and this is not f eight to e6
to deform like once I snide on deform
web will be very nicely positioned
actually this route can also
the modified a bit oops I didn't want to
do that you can also sometimes go here
night bh to see 62 d for this ontology
but council here decided for whoops for
the for the other way to play rookie
aids in order to prepare night f8 and it
worked out very well for him i think
it's it's difficult and i'm not quite
sure at which point white really went
wrong here because i think after let's
say move 18 or 19 black was very very
okay and he only played absolutely
standard moves I mean this is very well
known this maneuver i played this
opening is blank also and i can very
much imagine myself playing this stuff
it's nothing um nothing spectacular just
was black or black is doing in this kind
of lines so McShane went king h1 which
seems to be a preparing move fire form
and yeah so it happens nine of eight
knight to e to which was obviously the
idea of 93 to get the light e 2 2 g-3
now c5 blocking the center now white can
forget about playing deform and black
has a very nice central bind here with
his pawns the only thing which might
look a bit ugly at the moment at least
temporarily is this Bishop which is
blocked in but this can very often be
activated on f8 to h6 if black plays g6
at some point we will see this at the
end the game also so this is not a very
in this Bishop much more important is to
get the central grip going here yes c5
white went on 9h for okay the ideas to
to maybe put the night here 96 not f5
Bishop to f8 so black um still secures
his bishop he's got two bishops and he
sees some future for this piece on h6
possibly so it's no use to let this
bishop yeah getting exchange
which also would help wyd a lot in terms
of maybe playing for kind of drawers
George position because it would have
had opposite colored bishops what I'm
talking about is if black let's say it
would place a mother not a move let's
say here white might consider at some
point to just capture here and I mean
even this is somewhat uncomfortable for
black but let's say here and there form
and then you get those opposite colored
bishops which are very often on young a
factor for getting to a very Jewish
position and also this lots of stuff
exchanged here and well black has a
little bit of a space advantage she had
the scent and he doesn't want to
exchange so many pieces so Bishop
evaders perfectly understandable move so
on yeah here white went back to e3 I
mean the night is not doing much on a
father can almost get kicked with g6 ya
na 94 but wanted to go all along and ya
know white went f4 to get some activity
going on the FR you should be six takes
takes 91 obviously preparing the next
move g6 and this is the position which I
reached and when I went to look through
the game before I this when I decided to
to to coverage here in the video and
here I ask myself what what did right
what did why do wrong before because
this position is some I mean white
doesn't have any active play here not
not at all and the only question is can
he can you hold this position against
the blacks plans black it's the only is
the only one here you can do something
he can yeah for one thing activate his
bishop it was just one thing which isn't
so terrible but it's it's an idea we
should match six pretty nice square and
he's got all the
all the porn breaks here why doesn't
have any porn break left like has got
let's say ideas like here or here he can
actually move something on the on the
queenside um if why it moves something
on the queenside I meet pawns then he
just weakened so his position actually
this is what he did and I'm pretty much
I mean he played c3m and after this it's
very obvious that black is is first very
fine I mean just the question is he
slightly better clearly better after
this move and of course McShane was
perfectly aware of the consequences the
thing is if you don't play this move you
need to play against this this terrible
night here all the time I mean c3 it's
the only poor move which really yeah
throw this night out of your chem and
it's a constant annoyance annoyance you
this piece it always takes you to hear
and you need to do something about it
i'm just not sure if c3 really yeah if
the QR may be here is worse than than
the disease so to say because it I mean
just have a look at this see three
weekends d3 quickens b3 and that pretty
much kills this [ __ ] this Bishop also i
mean this bishop was was a bad piece
anyway but I mean bad pieces may be too
harsh but not know that means psets
doing very much the only role in this
game is to at some point maybe take the
night yeah it's difficult I mean
somewhere before I think McShane must
have done something wrong but it's hard
to point out without investing really
lots of time into this position on this
game so yeah maybe you should have kept
a more passive approach here like player
maybe Knight f3 are 22 or whatever Queen
d2 Bishop f6 maybe not but and it's
difficult it's not an easy position to
play at all but t3 I think makes it
quite
I mean it is blacks plans are very
obvious after the smooth um he okay he
just stepped back here and then um
Knight to f3 Bishop g7 covering the five
square and preventing any D for ideas
and knock winning one which is a tricky
move may be very unlikely that he really
expected I'd like to take on d3 it's a
neat trick I mean what would let play
black played a five which is a really
good strategical move trying to attack
this weakness on b3 and play against the
Queen side on what you need to look at
is oops this one here we want of course
queen dee threesome of where which you
need to need to check but it's a very
very dangerous for black to check this
phone let's say rookie one like him like
no tech SIA 95 is a bit embarrassing why
does the screen go now so black a motegi
form you need to drop back to to be five
here and then White has has this idea
nadji five and maybe night d5 to come
and this is has greatly activated oops
wrong he and greatly activated White's
pieces I mean he's got really active
play now and I mean it looks it looks
bad just here just optically it look it
looks bad for black but if you ask the
computers it's already pretty much
clearly better for white so this is far
too risky to to take the pawn in the
game as mentioned it just went a five
which is just the better the good
strategic move um here you can also have
a brief look at the time spent so Magnus
after 21 minutes is on one hour seven
minutes left so he didn't really spend
much time on the game which is not too
surprising I mean all those moves are
pretty much obvious I mean this is what
i was saying black wasn't doing
something revolutionary great here he
just played the normal plan and white
sort of drifted into problems so under
quite sure what he did wrong it makes
Shane down to 16 minutes he spent lots
of time he always wants to try and
travel in this in this tournament so how
do you react now to to a five you cannot
play a mechanical clock a four wedges b3
is hanging maybe black cannot take it
about a four is just terrible anyway so
not quite sure what white should be
doing it's hard to avoid any any
weaknesses now on the queenside at the
end he decided to play rook t1 covered
III now I know a phone to capture um
okay and now you see lots of weakness is
he on the queenside and pretty miserable
bishop and b2 so the whole Queen side is
an area where black dominates and he
needs to control the position and at
some point we'll get some some great
endgame if nothing particularly bad is
happening so on in the game he continued
with rook f8 activating the rook on this
half open a file we should to see one I
mean this Bishop didn't do anything on
b2 so make sense Queen to g3 maybe
intending a night move to to g5 and
black attack this rukia winning it to
tempo and so at this kind of position if
you give this to to a computer it's it's
it actually tells you i mean this this
is a move that Duke McShane played and
heathyr the computer things
the key error because black and take I
mean it's no big surprise that black can
take the pawn of coffee he saw that the
computer actually says okay you can play
here Bishop h6 and then turn back here
with the Queen to cover the tech night
and the computer actually assesses this
position as slightly better for black
but this for human this is really super
awkward to play this kind of position so
it's very understandable that McShane
didn't want to get into this kind of
tighter position I mean it's completely
why doesn't have any harmony going its
position at all so he decided to play
Ruby one and actually just sacrifice
sacrifice the d3 porn the idea was to
get maybe some play on the on the
kingside very understandable decision
you don't want to yeah sort of sit in
waiting in a passive position and wait
until you get get a bad end game and
better to maybe sacrifice upon trying to
muddy the waters so yeah black returned
his suspicions to to help defending
which makes sense night check here ok
king moose don't want to exchange you're
defending bishop Queen to h4 and white
he has a little bit of counter play i
would say against the blacks king it's
not entirely clear katia at least from
practical point of view I mean the
computer gives the success almost
winning for black but well we're not
computer so the computers adjuster yeah
just a tour which helped us maybe
understand and and analyze chess better
but it's to assess position to assess
positions between human players the
computers are very limited importance
because sometimes positions just
terribly difficult to play if you only
have really have those only moves you
need to find those only moves
very little time so for back to the
point of your disposition is not such an
easy win for for black okay i won Bishop
g5 which is I think yeah makes make
sense and now you see that white really
has got some pieces near the king of
course quickly this was not possible
because like black checkmates on the
back rank so otherwise of course you
would have liked to take with the night
but not possible here Queen takes and
here actually the computer and has an
improvement for four cards in here I
think it's a pretty clear improvement if
you look at it but not at all easy to
see he could have played rook to f4 hear
what he played is a very natural move
from let's show its King g7 it's very
natural to to get the king up here sort
of a tech the night so that White's
queen is somehow tied to this night
always needs to defend it and it's in
this a supernatural move to play um yeah
what what Allah said the computer wants
to go here sort of taking away squares
from the Queen so that it cannot um
retreat at some point maybe help defend
the Queen side and after that the
computer basically just wants to eat up
the coincide and says black black is not
mated well it's a easy for the computer
to see to watch it yet to say in in a
way to give it it in analysis but it's
not at all easy to decide to play such a
somewhat loose looking move like rook 2f
form so um at the end oops here we were
to mainline young okay at the end King
g7 played so on it's not it's not bad
also yeah it's now I'm Queen to see one
which has two ideas defend those pawns
for move now but also
intending on I to g5 getting a piece and
more pieces into the attack using the
second night also and this also protects
everyone so this is a nice move which
combines defensive ideas with aggressive
intentions of 95 so at this point I
think white has some some kind of
practical play here and here um mungus
playgroup to f4 so a similar idea as
before um he had alternative circus
could have played queen to d6 to e7 to
get the Queenie to defend so are the
moose at this point here I think I
McShane played rookie one you see yet
one minute left so very difficult to
play this year maybe Im another idea not
maybe another idea definitely was Knight
to g5 which is quite interesting because
it immediately attacks the air form of
point here threatening just rookie r4
takes and Quint eggs and black needs to
react to this somehow and hindi hip like
actually needs to be be precise um let's
say if black takes here just for
instance so it's not the best move here
and now the bishop is hanging on only
six let's say black plays an active move
here there should be three then wider
has a pretty surprising move at his
disposal he can play c4 which is very
very weird-looking move in a way because
it's double protected here but it forces
in a way black to take this porn because
white also has the idea of 96 and look
to sm I mean Roop to f7 is the stronger
threat it's just a made threats look to
f7 King takes h6 route 2h7 checkmate so
may put this on the board if black would
do some nothing move here then why'd
will check here this is immediate mate
so takes here and then oops not this one
rook rook takes h7 of course and also
checkmate so what has strong threats Ian
Black most likely at the c4c phone needs
to need to check this he takes with the
Queen we have the same idea here so
black actually would need to two sec the
Queen here to this kind of position and
it's certainly not the thing that black
had in mind here he was very much better
now needs to defend this weird position
here so I'm after here to to get this
get this again on the board um black
might need to take here with the water
bishop and then white can nom what can
play work to do one with the idea book
d7 and now it it gets it gets very
tricky I think black needs to take here
here here and this ends in a draw check
here and funny enough after move luck
here wide returns and black doesn't have
anything better than King edge six again
okay but well this these are not lines
that you can calculate with one minute
on the clock so time management really
an essential factor here in this game
McShane won't form when for another move
but let's just check briefly what would
have been good actually for black he
could have played also if white would
have gone 95 our queen to d6 which is
sort of controlling Mafia controlling
the position a possible continuation I
can only show the outline see it's
really complicated route d1 let's say
I'm Queen to e5 p.m. takes
x f4 and then move like here white
always needs to protect this night so it
cannot take care because black just
captures so let's say here and here and
this position is still very much better
for black the problem being that this
night on age 6 is somewhat stranded it
always needs protection from from the
Queen and black has also the better
structure with a brilliant not only five
so like is also better here but maybe 95
would have been better from a practical
point of view hard to tell okay in the
game it pretty much ended um without
much of a fight i think carlton just
controlled the the position and sort of
wrapped it up nicely rook f8 um yeah i
mean know if oops blank would have taken
here you need to account i need to look
at this move pinning pinning the rook
and this rook world will get lost so he
just played a normal strengthening moves
here i mean this this piece is start
going anywhere so this also explains
here the following moves nyjah five g3
rook f2 and those nights are looking
like active pieces but they are somewhat
stranded they have no no way back here
the night on age six energy fight they
have absolutely no square that can go to
and I mean one minute on the clock for
such a position against 40 minutes it's
just brutal so look if 295 sort of yet
desperation move I mean this night was
just hanging and black was threatening
all kinds of stuff um so he tried to get
in a check here but just rook king 2 h8
and now we all move 40 and well the time
travel
silver also from akshay Nia and the tie
me now head will spin to check if he has
got some last kind of swindling chance
here and he doesn't mainly because I
mean back as a pawn up the P sub but
also threatening Queen to d4 to g2 mate
oops not to f2 to g2 so wyd would let's
say play this year attacking the rook
and I can take here and just check mate
so on it's a pretty weird game if you if
you look at this it's hard to tell it is
for me um maybe someone else watching
this understand this kind of structure
better but on it was hard for me to tell
where wide really went wrong here I
think this kind of position is really a
little bit without any prospects I mean
you can play it and it's solid and so on
but it's you cannot do much and black
hair Scott is the only one to have some
active ideas on the queenside this kind
of structure which which happened I mean
c3 looks very debatable but it's not not
very convenient anyway so what we
interesting to hear what the players are
thinking what was maybe the inaccuracies
or maybe they just they don't see this
pic this position as being so were so
terrible for white mean c3 is really a
huge concession to play so I'm very
difficult after this I think it was
really an uphill struggle white maybe
could have put up some slightly tougher
resistance but even also looking at the
clocks yeah white was also done on time
I think this is murderous to to play
this against I mean the strongest player
in the world on the other side very very
very bad afternoon you get into this
kind of stuff I think why can't imagine
I mean I never played such a strong
player so okay this was some a game from
the final round I'm very nice play from
from
nice very has a very it had a very
logical flow to it now preparing this
this night maneuver here oops yeah this
why I came I should be able to draw
arrows why can't I do it yeah not sure
why but well this kind of night maneuver
here maybe I should reword or museum
maybe yeah now it's working this kind of
night maneuver it's very very stunned
standard in this position but he's sort
of executed that in the purest possible
form sort of a model game for black site
in this in this opening and yeah how to
tell where wide really went astray here
until then a very good mop-up job here
maybe this night g5 would have been a
bit more testing I mean in this position
instead of Ruby one this 95 maybe was a
bit more more challenging but black was
better than anyway it's really hard to
overcome those those stranded pieces
let's turn the piece on h6 yeah well
thanks for watching and yeah I'm trying
to update the channel regularly with ya
buried content so I'm trying to put up
various different videos i think what i
will do is soon again is some sort of
book reviews um I hope you you're
interested in this this is well and also
i will continue at some point this eve
45 repertoire serious some next video
will be about the Scotch game from Lex
point of view but these are always
really tough work to to prepare so it's
nothing that I can do off hand so to say
and not a quick quick job to do yeah
thanks for watching and on yeah leave
any questions or comments on this video
on YouTube and are trying to answer
questions or read your comments of
thanks and bye